you nervous yeah
right this is where the rubber hits the
road you know I feel quite vulnerable
yeah just you have no idea what's going
to happen really no idea and
afternoon my name is Richard and I'm
standing as an independent candidates at
the general election in May and
inequality is getting wider hey
even with the support of a major
political party running in a general
election is tough doing it independently
is something that very few have
succeeded in less than half a dozen
independence have been elected since
1950 but despite this every general
election sees hundreds try to win a seat
on their own absolutely jump in stow it
got away and this year the British
politics so unpredictable independence
around the country are feeling
optimistic this is the story of one's
life to go it alone in the general
election just behind us is where where
our SAT having a coffee one day and just
looks out over there I'm just knew that
this place had a significant place in my
future and I didn't know what that meant
at the time no item and it wasn't until
about 18 months ago that I just knew
that I had to stand at this election is
an independent I'll be fine chartered by
tax advisor Richard Lutz and Darnell
from Cheltenham is one of about twenty
five independent candidates who've so
far declared their intentions to stand
he has no political history but dreams
of being an MP and thinks that this
election is his best chance I just feel
that there's there is more possibility
of this happening right now than there
has ever been but doing what I'm doing
you know outside of a party system
history has not been kind to
independence despite some candidates
going to extreme lengths
is the only light this is mr. none of
the above he changed his name in 2010 in
the hope to stand out you know I didn't
want to be an MP I wanted to give
ordinary people more of a an involvement
in day-to-day running of the country and
I thought if I was an MP that was a way
of doing it didn't work out that well
for me actually but there you go I took
three months off work I got two hundred
and two votes going to the count and
watching everyone's pile growing and not
mine that was very demoralizing what
would be your advice to someone who's
standing an independent this year don't
expect to win don't even try to win of
course but do you think we might have
one did you actually think it is
convince those absolutely convinced I
was gonna win I've not done thousands of
doors I'd given out thousands of
leaflets myself personally to people I
thought they were gonna vote for me
didn't happen
first things first a cup of tea cup of
tea so how're things going then how long
we've got how long we've got until it's
a relation day yeah yeah well because
you're involved in issues you start
actually realizing and counting so it's
107 days today working our way towards
that 100 days to go which is going to be
quite pivotal I think so let's have a
look at your video okay this is a sort
of a big moment in your campaign isn't
it it is I was thinking about this this
morning there's business measure what
Sarah hi Sarah okay it's been various
steps along the way where you think yeah
this is actually real you know what I'm
doing is is not just a dream or an idea
is is stuff going on you know after i
said i was going to stand the first
person who i met you said I'm gonna vote
for you yeah all of a sudden it's like
one vote Wow dad got one but okay in a
bit like two votes at that forget I've
got an idea which way I'm leaning Sarah
what do you think about your husband
devoting what is going to be the next
few months to what some would say is the
impossible dream of becoming an MP I'd
like to see it as impossible I mean for
him he's talked about politics his whole
life and as long as I've known him and
he's always been passionate about it I
know a little he knows a lot because
that's what he loves the kids were kids
they're almost adults love it very
passionate to see their dad standing for
something he believes in gonna win i
think he could the feedback I've seen
from people is all your independent or
would you stand for what what are you
talking about and they're they're
interested there immediately oh you're
not standing for a party right so what
have you got to say gotta press the ball
yeah thank you so here we go world watch
the video okay
hi my name is Richard loves and Darnell
and I'm standing as an independent
candidate at the 2015 general election
we need our government to turn around
and face us the people Richard is up
against it in his constituency
Cheltenham is considered a Lib Dem
stronghold the bookies give him
unflattering odds Richard lup's and
Darnell the independent candidate here
we make him 100 to 1 so again not very
much chance independence it's very very
difficult for them to break through in
sticks like this the Tories and the
Liberal Democrats will be spending a lot
resource here they'll have lots of
campaigners out spending plenty of money
here and for an independent candidate to
break through in a cig like this very
difficult very rarely happens but one
man who upset the bookies in 2001 is
independent dr. Richard tape 28 phone I
really appreciate sharing a coffee with
somebody who's been around this Luke's
recites I think no no no no I did two
session to session that I didn't get
back in on the third occasion but I'd
like to have another go and see if I
could get back over there because it's a
wonderful thing being there with no
width and being able to vote with the
government when they're right and
against them when they're obviously
wrong as surfing
you need three things to have a chance
you need to have an unpopular sitting MP
or ruling government and that could be
the case now a high-profile well-known
local can and I'm afraid being a doctor
helps tremendously Richard with what
you've heard today from the other
Richard what do you make of his chances
then I think because he's against a very
popular MP I think the chances I'm
afraid I think of small I don't want to
put him off because he's got absolutely
the right ideas about why he should do
it and it's something he wants to do
very badly I think the main thing is
enjoyed and it is great fun and if you
get there then it's it's superb and if
you get there and I get there then that
would be absolutely great
I'm feeling after that I feel inspired
and the time has come where I just need
to get out there and just blatantly ask
people you know I need to get over some
reticence just expecting what I'm saying
and what I'm you know the fact that i'm
standing and I'm getting more visible to
actually just do the deal and it's not
the reason why I'm standing in May is
that I'm not satisfied with where we are
as a country and service is critical
when it comes to politics and it comes
to our government I shall be here for
most of the next 100 days and I ask your
vote this election
Oh